Fred you look beautiful uh hey hey
they're sleeping yeah that's so nice
that's so cute
wake the [ __ ] up
oh my god I'm so ugly all right let's
get a head to tattoo okay I can get a
skull face
that's cool yeah let's get that yeah not
now I'm ugly forever yeah perfect
I'm at the church so I'll meet you in
the church all right hey now yeah I'm
gonna pray to UM to Lord man coming here
yeah oh man I can oh oh oh [ __ ] oh yeah
great job I still stuck on the ground
don't worry get on the back it'll be all
right all right all right all right now
no no okay all right Oh goody-goody Jame
all right all right
what is this Matthew McConaughey yeah
super excited oh hey I read Brad I'm so
excited - yeah I'm a big fan I love hurt
which trees in the car all right
oh my god his team won where's his team
- what is this fight oh my god we're
gonna get him up it's like some like
some gang and like a anime or something
right yeah this is enemies [ __ ] oh he
has a car oh oh oh
someone killed himself
the guy look in the street I [ __ ] the
guy up
oh yes I follow what you gonna gun for
listen can we get get out of the vehicle
mommy you need to stop mommy mommy I got
the cool angles going this is pretty
badass
Emma do you see that you that finger
yeah oh yeah man these angles I've got a
cool angles going as well but on the end
right yeah you should probably do that
goes yeah
here we go hey you're flipping out of
your window it's a long time oh oh dude
there's a sweet-ass jump here there's a
sick horse jump take that jump on yeah
oh go [ __ ] with averey wait up for me
please
ready yeah granny you're the wrong side
I can't get hurt
granny see now she just know what you
see you in a confused now I got a gay
the cat agree I take the blue paint say
no video of Dubois
oh can I hijack a coach flight like a
proper [ __ ] jumbo jet
it was the most British I've ever heard
you say ha ha ha I'll get my keys jumbo
like a proper [ __ ] problem jack a
proper [ __ ] jumbo jet mate oh my god
let's get in there pretty hey he was
[ __ ] yeah all right I mean yeah you
better you best get in this plane boy
[ __ ] oh you're dead buddy
blocked my clean so I couldn't go [ __ ]
don't blame me I'm playing first-person
mode it's so cozy I'm sitting next to
Ken how you do nice hair Chen sis you
like that no I'm out someone else yeah
someone else huh you jumped out I
couldn't take it anymore
I can only aim a pistol at the back of
us he can't put my feet what are you
doing back there any particular jab
Jesus and thought this was my hand oh a
cholita granny fights the heart meds
boys I don't know where I am
granny you're safe put the gun down
granny
but we're good red bother them is he
still [ __ ] dancing 92 Brady never put
the gun down
no no way specificity outlast way is
immersing the worst crude drive a car
with this one guy flipping me off in the
face and grind answer you [ __ ] got it
bill the point is are you hit Oh
ready great no great you're like
right now it's my boy Kenneth great
enough ready over and she fell off a
card oh yeah you can start over again
the pain goes just over this here we're
just showing each other we're right
there by the bingo oh my god you're
right your invite I know my way to bingo
I may not know my own name anymore boy
but I know my way to bingo yeah don't
sleep granny off you greedy high you
know I your daddy aquiline old woman you
little [ __ ] come on Wyatt you even kill
me before I come on you little [ __ ] Oh
ready ready see mortals
oh my boy kill me like I killed your
grandpa I wish you I knew escena thank
you oh jesus oh my god [ __ ] granny
man
jung chung ui-hwa
we're going down we're going down man
Mayday Mayday